what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are well really like Shazam
has finally come back in DC Comics and I
know a lot of people are just like oh my
god thank God because it's it's one of
those like presences that was hugely
missed like you can't launch DC rebirth
you know some two years ago or whatever
it was it launched and then not have
Shazam and then just kind of leave it
that way I mean he was non-existent
there was no indication he was there
outside of an appearance from like
Hellblazer rebirth like that was it and
so the question everybody's been asking
here is where has Billy Batson been and
what has Billy Batson been doing now a
little bit of backstory here this is
actually kind of important and the
reason why is because Geoff Johns just
sort of picks up and it and it works for
what it is but it does require a little
bit of explanation
so when DC rebooted back in 2011 with
new 52
Shazam did not receive a solo series
instead he was a backup feature in the
Justice League and this is a lot of lay
a lot of this because he hadn't really
been able to hold a solo book for some
time but it was also a way to kind of
keep people to introduce people to his
character and what was considered to be
one of the best-selling books that that
DC had at the time it was covered
between issue justice league issues 9
and 21 his backup features but it was a
consistent write like you would go 9 10
11 12 and then there would be nothing
for 13 or 14 and then you would go into
15 it'll be nothing for 16 or 17 then
you go into you know 18 19 20 21 and and
what that what the new 52
Shazam book did is it laid the
groundwork for dr. sivana who is
probably are we consider to be the
arch-nemesis of Billy Batson even if
black Addams more popular and then it
basically said okay there's Billy Batson
it laid his character out there was the
the what will become the marshes am
family and then you had kind of the
origin of how he got his powers and then
you had him fight like Adam and then it
was done and that was it and that that's
all you really had so it was really more
like a teaser than anything else it was
really like a story arc like a singular
story arc spread over the course of you
know what amounted to like 10 or really
about 12 or 13 hearts and then that was
it and so what this does is immediately
jump into it and so this kind of picks
up with the the the Captain Marvel
family of Shazam family already existing
now the fun thing about this is that
when it comes to Shazam one of the big
things that people didn't like about
Billy's character when the new 52 first
launched is that he was dark and cynical
well he was just uses a mean little kid
and the whole idea behind this in terms
of how Geoff Johns had written him is
that he was a kid who had been bounced
from foster home to foster home as we
had a very very very hard life when he
finally was a place in a Vasquez home
that's what he ran into like Freddie
Freeman and Maher
all those characters who would go on to
become the Shazam family but at the time
he didn't mesh well with them it wasn't
until he was taken before the wizard
Shazam given his powers and then sent
back to earth that he began to gain a
new understanding for the significance
of family with them being his supporting
characters especially going into the
final black Adam that's when they all
began to grow closer and it wasn't until
Justice League number 21 in the final
part of the story that Billy realized he
needed allies and then he bestowed a
portion of his power onto the rest of
the adopted kids and they became the
Shazam family and so what this does is
pick up a year after that nine months
after that but it might as well be a
year because the amount of time that
passed but it picks up after that point
in time so again it's a little murky in
terms of windows takes place
chronologically it says it takes place
today but what that basically argues
what it basically says is everything
between the time that Shazam first you
know gained his powers and the time that
the Shazam family was born up till now
has only been a year in DC comics take
it for what it's worth you know you kind
of run late if you want to but the fact
remains that we basically end up picking
up in a in the Museum of American
Revolution and this again this is kind
of cool because when Billy became a
superhero then he became the Billy
Batson that fans had known and
recognized from back in the 90s named
before then when they used to read his
character and so when you get in here
there's kind of like goofing off okay it
looks like they're having like the most
fun like it looks it looks fun it's kind
of funny here because Freddy Freeman was
always kind of like the cut-up of the
group while he was always a kid he was
just kind of like you know goofy and a
mess around like the devil make here
kind of attitude
whereas Billy was more of like some
middle ground he's like the Mario of the
group right like the balanced character
even if Luigi can't jump higher in Mario
2 which despite what video game donkey
says is not the best the greatest game
of all time not even close um but but
the fact remains here that in this
instance he's just kind of the care to
the cuts up and has a good time and so
what this whole thing goes on these guys
basically break into the museum in order
to rob like you know these old artifacts
and then presumably sell them on the
black marker so I'm like that it's
probably the worst decision that a
person could have made because they
basically run into a place that
currently contains a whole bunch of
teenagers who shot the word Shazam and
basically becomes Superman and so like
they're fighting an army of Superman and
it's in and there's a terrible decision
they were not prepared that's basically
what happens with these guys you know
Billy bass was the first one to call it
he pops up and bam they're all they're
all there they start cleaning house I
mean absolutely way is that they
literally start cleaning house now
business desire to kind of showcase how
they function together that's the nature
of
for those you guys who are new to comic
books it's one of the things that
writers will hit on when they're
bringing characters back when they're
introducing characters for the first
time like new x-men or when their
interview when they're whether when
they're coming through this like okay
here's a new roster of x-men you know
then like you'll get a series of story
arcs that showcase their individual
personalities and then how they mesh as
a team and how those individual
personalities content will conflict and
that'll take 18 issues or something
along those lines to flesh out you know
three story arcs but with something like
this you're basically bringing the
Shazam family back and so it kind of
picks up as if you never left off and it
works because what this does is it
basically gives the old Shazam fans kind
of just like hey guys so we're
continuing all the business as usual and
and they don't feel like they really
missed out on anything
though for the new fans they get an idea
of what the Shazam family's about all
the same time wanting to go back and see
older things it makes them nostalgic for
an age of comics they hadn't read and so
it's it's pretty cool it is a pretty
cool way to make it work of course this
whole skirmish is over quick fast and in
a hurry and here's a funny thing they
can't think up a name for themselves
they can't think up a name for their
group and it's kind of funny because
I'll be honest man like you got to have
a cool name you cannot become a
superhero team and then call yourself
anything well you can't be like we're
the people who do things but you can't
you can't call yourself that but you
have to have like a cool name honestly I
don't know okay here's a question for
you guys if you guys had to think up a
name for the Shazam family that's not
called the Shazam family what would you
call them like what would the name be
like I'm kind of curious you know like
Thundercats oh I don't know I don't know
what I would call it I think it'd be
kind of cool anyway so so they're just
kind of like goofing off trying to
figure out what their names gonna be the
council like let's just chalk it up to
Superman and they basically end up
leaving and so again like from there
they trapped a transition back home now
again not a whole lot is happening here
in terms of like fast-paced action
razzle dazzle no that stuff's really
happening it's kind of getting us
reacquainted with the characters getting
us reacquainted with reacquainted with a
team member this is issue number one so
it's not really designed to have a whole
lot of things happening and one of the
things that you know for those guys who
were new one of the things that existing
couple of fans will tell you is that
when it comes to Geoff Johns it's always
a slow burn Geoff Johns will never like
have this great big huge grandiose event
that'll happen over the span of like six
issues it'll take like 12 or 18 or like
24 or sometimes even 50 some-odd issues
for the event to reach its conclusion
and to have this huge finality and
climax he's very Jonathan Hickman in
that regard nonetheless you know with
them getting back home it's very much
just like you know kids meshing together
and having a good time and that's kind
of a cool thing is this is stork Lee
differ from how it was when Billy first
showed up and that's the great thing
about this is again for an
for older fans that is kind of
continuing on for new fans it's
something new but for older fans is kind
of a reward is a payoff for due
diligence it's a payoff for sticking
around saying you know yes I read the
new 52 run in the back you know in the
in the pages of Justice League and yes I
follow the later Justice League stories
were Shazam was part of the team and
y'all during dark side Ward all I kind
of stuff and so I said well you laughter
Trinity Ward you know and forever evil
and whatnot yes I follow all that kind
of stuff but like I've been a fan ever
since and like yes we're picking back up
again and yes I remember all this you
know it's like a little bit of nostalgia
for series of stories they haven't read
in over three years
and so when you jump into this whole
thing there's a sort of you know like
hey like like we let's go do stuff you
know there's stuff I want to show you
guys so it's like they all raised from
the table all the pair's like where you
guys go on it's like we all got to do
homework which is no answer any kid ever
gave any parent ever that's not like
like right off of the bat they know
there's something's wrong because like
no kid wants to do homework but in the
last year once they actually get into
the rock of eternity it's kind of an
important thing here what they've done
is they've kind of turned the rock of
eternity into their base of operations
slash trophy room you know now they call
themselves the actual Shazam family and
that's really kind of what they are at
the moment but this is a little more
important than it seems to be and the
reason why is because they're taking
these small moments to celebrate things
with each other they're taking these
small moments to talk about things that
they've done and you know sort of
celebrating the history of their group
as a whole because with them all having
these sort of superhero powers all of
which were bestowed by Billy its unified
them in a way that they really didn't
think was possible when they first met
they have a common theme here
you know they fight as a superhero team
they've experienced loss these are the
things that are important in terms of
how they look at the world not only that
one thing also bear in mind is the rock
of eternity is empty now
and it has been for some time the wizard
Shazam aura really the wizard ma'am
again who gave Billy Batson his powers
he died almost immediately after that
happened and so Billy was just kind of
left to his own devices with no real
guidance no real mentorship that's
really what he saw his character grow
when it came to the Justice League
comics because he looked at Batman
Superman Wonder Woman the Trinity of
superheroes and even others as major
influences in how he should act in
function it was very reminiscent of the
old-school Justice League Unlimited
cartoon when Shazam showed up for the
first harm and then fought Superman and
then was basically at the end was like
you guys aren't heroes you guys are
people masquerading as heroes but you're
not heroes you've forgotten what it
means to be a hero and then walks away
which was awesome can we all just agree
the fight between Shazam and Superman
and Justice League Unlimited was Bruce
on her man watch that Sue's like it done
with it dude he thrashed Superman I'm
sorry I'm so excited people but
what also happens here is Eugene has
actually kind of been mapping through
the rock of eternity he's been going
through and saying okay look there's
really nobody here anymore but there's
all this information that's here there's
all these things are here these old
rooms that are impossible to access or
you know these hallways that go nowhere
different things like that so we're
gonna map the whole place and we're
gonna figure out what's going on
somewhere along the line there was a
wall as part of the rock of eternity and
it's gone now and it leads down to this
place they call this station now where
the station will you know what it leads
to we don't know we don't know if it
leads to like alternate realities other
dimensions we're not sure but it does
allow for geoff johns to kind of set the
stage of exploration for the Shazam
family as they go through and start
seeing where these different trains go
to but it is kind of a cool thing
because what we enter what we end up
being told is that they basically travel
to a place called a magic land and
that's when we started to get this
explanation here the magic lands as are
explained here seem to basically be
places or magic reigns supreme in some
form or fashion and and that's kind of
important here and the reason why is
because if you go and you look at the
number of places that seemed to exist
here in the magic lands there's seven of
them and the reason why that matters is
because originally when new 52 first
launched we got the history of the rock
of eternity and so on there were seven
wizards and sorcerers who governed magic
who basically existed to protect magic
somewhere along the line black Adam went
crazy and killed all but the the wizard
that gave Billy his powers but they seem
to have probably operated out of these
places or hailed from these places as it
was Billy discovering his own lineage in
a lot of different ways now this is all
stuff that would have been taught to him
had the wizard remained alive but he's
discovering all these things and so by
discovering all these things what this
does is it gives him his own own
personal history now from there we
switch back over to the family of of the
Vasquez's now of course there's a couple
things going on here you got Freddy
Freeman who does kind of like hey so
like let's pull these levers and find
out where these trains go which is
exactly what I would do
oh yeah we definitely there'd be like
hey man it's like we probably shouldn't
pull these levers like walking house
we're gonna know where they go I'll be
reckless let's go on the adventure but
uh but once they yank it you know
literally like it seems to activate
everything and when that happens we end
up having a knock on the door of Billy
Batson's house the vasquez answer and is
basically billy batson father who says
he's here to see his son now one of the
things you guys will notice is that the
father of Billy Batson looks exactly
like Billy when he turns into Shazam and
the reason for that was established back
during the power of Shazam stories by
Jerry Ordway and one of the things that
you learned is that Billy Batson when he
turns in a Shazam he actually turns into
what he imagined his father to look like
and that's exactly how he looks so it's
kind of tragic and it's kind of sad but
it is cool without being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come this explain make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]